Welcome back everyone this is going to
be my ironman doctor strange 2 video
recently the marvel writers have been answering
questions about bringing the iron man character
back in the mcu and explains a lot about how
marvel is going to handle the iron man related
stories during marvel phase 4 because there are
a couple of them coming up in all the movies and
disney plus series so we'll break it all
down there's a bunch of cool easter eggs
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we have moon
night episodes starting soon and i will be doing
videos for all those episodes those episodes are
actually going to overlap with the release
of doctor strange multiverse of madness but
recently you've probably been seeing a lot of news
about iron man coming back in the movie in doctor
strange 2 and not just any iron man an iron man
variant or one from another universe however you
want to think about him played by another actor
there's been reports of a number of different
multiverse based characters from other universes
like from the fox x-men movies having cameo scenes
mcu variants of doctor strange himself like
we've already seen three different versions
of doctor strange in the trailer already there's
reports about multiple versions of scarlet witch
other avengers characters so it makes sense that
you see a lot of news about versions of iron man
showing up in the film like marvel is using
the doctor strange multiverse of madness movie
to take the loki variance concept to the extreme
degree why the hell is there an alligator in here
but just recently the writers from spiderman
no way home did this big interview big podcast
about the movie and during it they talked a lot
about the iron man character tony stark robert
downey jr in how kevin feige and the other marvel
powers that be who control everything are actually
approaching the iron man character just in general
during marvel phase 4. they were asked if there's
been any talk about bringing a version of iron
man back in the movies because there are so many
multiverse based movies coming up like spider-man
no way home was a multiverse or spider-verse movie
doctor strange multiverse of madness literally
has multiverse in the title so there are so many
ways that you could bring a version of iron
man back beyond him just being a variant or
a virgin from another universe but this is the
clip of them talking about iron man coming back
ever any talk about having iron man return i mean
i think honestly that's like a non-starter in the
halls of marvel at least in our experience they
just don't really like constantly invoking i mean
obviously tony cast such a large uh shadow even
after end game which we dealt with and far from
home but i think everyone felt like we can't just
keep on going to the tony well so if it wasn't
clear what they mean when they say that iron man
as a character just in general is a non-starter in
the halls of marvel is it all the writers on the
upcoming marvel phase 4 movies all the disney plus
series no matter what they are are not allowed to
use the iron man character the term non-starter
means that when someone brings up the name iron
man or tony stark in conversation with kevin feige
or the other producers talking about bringing
it back it immediately ends the conversation
is a hard pass from kevin foggy on bringing iron
man back in their reasoning just as they explained
during that clip is that kevin feige says they
can't keep going back to the iron man well they
need to find more creative solutions to dramatic
character arcs and these are the people that wrote
spider-man no way home and i do agree with them
that movie for example did not need iron man in it
as they say iron man casts a large shadow over the
movie you kind of feel it they do reference stark
industries for the mysterio drones plot and when
happy steals iron man's fabrication technology and
hides it in his apartment so they can use it later
so between that and what they're saying it's okay
to reference iron man tony stark but actually
bringing him back for cameo scenes in movies
crossovers is just a hard pass from marvel and
kevin feige so in related ironman news a lot of
you been asking me about all the doctor strange
two rumors there were rumors last year recently
that the movie would feature an alternate universe
iron man played by tom cruise of all people
if you've seen some of the fan art and you have
no idea what's going on like tom cruise why
would he be in a marvel movie there is a loose
connection between tom cruise and the mcu that
goes way back to marvel phase one because before
robert danny jr became iron man in the first movie
setting off the mcu in phase one tom cruise was
actually originally marvel's first pick for iron
man reportedly he was the person that they wanted
originally when they first started developing the
iron man project he wound up dropping out of
the movie early on over creative differences
with the script then marvel started looking at a
bunch of other actors sam rockwell for instance
who became justin hammer was also initially
considered for iron man tony stark early on
but ultimately they went with robert danny jr who
at the time was considered a huge risk for them
you have to remember this is way back in 2006 2007
when they're still developing the movie before
they started filming you probably heard john
favreau tell this story before at the time robert
downey jr's career wasn't doing that great he had
all kinds of trouble with the law he was in the
process of cleaning himself up john favreau pushed
for him they cast him and the rest was history it
all worked out perfectly for everyone it could
not have worked out better so in retrospect i am
very glad that we got robert downey jr instead
of tom cruise as iron man it would have been a
very very different mcu but when all this talk
of avengers variants being in doctor strange 2
started because kevin feige back at comic
con a couple years ago said that we'd see
other versions of avengers from other universes
in the movie that's probably when you started
seeing all the rumors in your timelines about
iron man tom cruise there's even been a rumor
recently that john krasinski is going to have
a cameo scene as an alternate version of reed
richards of the fantastic four is part of some
larger version of the illuminati during the movie
there have been many rumors about versions of the
illuminati having big cameo scenes but it would be
a multiverse version of the team so it wouldn't
be like the mcu illuminati although technically
it is kind of like the marvel cinematic multiverse
now so it is the mcu but it's kind of not the mcu
don't worry when the movie comes out i'll talk
about all those easter eggs i'll explain the
difference between these multiverse characters
and the core mcu characters that originate on
the original mcu earth it's the same thing when
you're talking about the loki series and all the
loki variants like who is the main loki what's
going on with these loki's from other timelines
i don't know if that john krasinski reed richard's
rumor is true marvel is working on a new fantastic
four movie and if he does cameo and doctor strange
2 is a variant of reed richards that effectively
confirms that he will not be the main mcu reed
richards but just based on what those spiderman no
way home writers are saying about marvel adamantly
being against bringing versions of iron man back
on screen i do not believe any of the tom cruise
iron man rumors to be true in most of the leaks
that you've probably seen circulating around
social media are just fan edits and photoshops
it's not like with the andrew garfield photoshop
situation where you're not sure if it's true or
not and andrew garfield himself is like it's
a photoshop but clearly seeing the movie we
know that was actually a scene during the
film like nope this is definitely real
the scene of him that leaked out was when they
were on the statue of liberty and it was him and
tom holland spider-man talking to toby maguire's
spider-man about his organic web shooters
there were a lot of other deleted scenes that
the writers from spiderman no way home talked
about i'll do more videos about that when
they actually release some of those deleted
scenes later this month when the movie hits
digital i do think all these doctor strange
two x-men cameo scenes are legit there was some
official concept art of the movie that did get
released featuring what looks like a version
of patrick stewart's professor x in a floating
wheelchair designed to look exactly like the one
he uses in x-men the animated series everyone's
playing the theme song in their head right now
i even put it at the end of a lot of my videos
this scene just depicts a version of doctor
strange being brought before him for questioning
inside a very tech heavy room by ultron bots who
seem like they're being commanded by this version
of professor x now patrick stewart claimed
that a while ago he had meetings with marvel
about coming back for a version of professor x
and new mcu movies but declined because he was
so happy with the way that his character
went out during the logan wolverine movie
so this concept art scene of him in doctor
strange 2 might wind up being very different
in the theatrical cut if they didn't get rid
of it completely which does happen sometimes
like you'll see concept art for really cool scenes
that just either get deleted during the filming
process or they don't make it past the concept
phase like all the scenes of america chavez in
spiderman no way home like you can see her clearly
they plan to put her in the movie initially
originally they were going to release doctor
strange 2 first she was going to show up for the
first time in that like this is her in the trailer
seeing her in the mcu for the first time then she
was going to show up in spider-man no way home
after that and help spider-man with his problem
but because they wound up releasing spider-man
first they just got rid of all of her scenes
it sounds like a lot of these x-men cameo scenes
that we're going to get in doctor strange 2 are
related to this big multiverse illuminati team
there was also some concept art that leaked out
of professor x fighting a version of scarlet
witch but she wasn't wearing her new costume
and she looked a little bit different so it could
have been a scarlet witch from another universe
and i know that raises a whole bunch of questions
because scarlet witch is supposed to be a nexus
being and there's only supposed to be one of her
in the entire multiverse but it sounds like they
might be changing that for the mcu they kind of
started to set that concept up during wandavision
with all the nexus easter eggs originally doctor
strange was going to be the doctor she sees in
this fake commercial during this episode giving
her the prescription so they'll answer a lot of
those questions during the movie and if marvel
is hardcore against bringing versions of iron man
back when we have the iron man wars episodes
and the iron heart episodes which are very
connected to the iron man mythos in the comics
it sounds like they'll just use the spider-man
no way home method for invoking iron man the
character like lots of references to shark
industries maybe some tony stark iron man name
drops but that's probably it like do not expect
tony stark to actually show up during armor wars
if robert downey jr does wind up coming back or a
version of iron man from the multiverse does wind
up showing up in a future movie early prediction
it'll be avengers secret wars so let me know
in the comments when do you actually think
we'll see a version of iron man or an alternate
universe iron man show up on screen or even robert
downey jr playing a multiverse version of another
character like a version of tony stark sorcerer
supreme from another universe they kind of did a
version of that during avengers infinity war but
it turned into a big deleted scene so hopefully
they'll pay that off at some point too don't worry
if we see references and easter eggs for iron
man i will point them out in my breakdown videos
but an easter egg and a reference isn't the same
thing as a full-blown cameo scene big reminder
my star wars book of boba fett episode 6 video
will post next be sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that in related marvel
news click here for that marvel secret invasion
first look video and click here for my eternals
thanos alternate ending video and easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!